auf diesen tag hatte sich josefine
hörste lange gefreut
heute schließt sie ihre ausbildung im
maritim magdeburg ab und eigentlich
sollte sie übernommen werden
doch daraus wird nun nichts das läuft
sehr großer schaut mal nach der
ausbildung ist man erstmal arbeitslos
und das möchte man nach der ausbildung
auf jeden fall nicht drei jahre lang
wurde sie zur hotelfachfrau ausgebildet
doch die korona pandemie macht die
zukunftspläne der 19-jährigen zunichte
es ist sehr enttäuschend da ist mein
traumberuf war schon immer und es ist
leider sehr traurig für einen selber und
auch für die familie
das abschlussfest am abend wird zur
traurigen abschiedsfeier für josefine
hörste und die anderen 14 azubis die nun
gehen müssen
hoteldirektoren andrea im valle wollte
sie alle übernehmen
tröstende worte zwei wochen lang das
restaurant geschlossen
ja und wir haben versucht so das beste
daraus zu machen
ja und ich hoffe dass ich den einen oder
anderen vielleicht mal wieder sehen
jetzt müssen sie die berufsanfänger
einen neuen arbeitgeber finden
also im moment habe ich leider keine
neue arbeit aber auf jeden fall
bewerbungen sind raus und irgendeiner
wird dabei sein
ich hoffe auch der hoteldirektorin fiel
die entscheidung sehr schwer
doch seit der korona krise sind die
einnahmen weggebrochen alles dreht sich
jetzt um abstandsregeln alles dabei und
dann fangen wir an allen stellen muss
auch noch gestellt
früher waren hier oft mehrere tausend
gäste pro tag die bleiben jetzt weg die
mitarbeiter sind in kurzarbeit und auch
für neue ausbildungsplätze ist kein geld
da ja normalerweise ist der tenor
eigentlich der
so viele leute wie aufhören stellen wir
auch wieder ein und das wäre ja 15
gewesen und jetzt haben wir gesagt gar
nicht auszubilden dass keine option
aber aufgrund der aktuellen lage dass
wir nur die hälfte der auszubildenden
dann im bei uns dann im august beginnen
können die soziologin heike solga hat
mögliche folgen der pandemie für den
ausbildungsmarkt untersucht und warnt
vor einer generation corona es wenn das
bruttoinlandsprodukt um circa sieben
prozent sinkt was nicht unrealistisch
ist das dann circa 45.000
ausbildungsplätze wegfahren das circa
90.000 jugendliche unvermittelt sich
beworben haben also damit haben wir eine
ein großteil der kurorte der die sehr
leer ausgehen wird
dabei wollte die bundesregierung genau
das verhindern stellt das eigens dafür
aufgestellte programm vor
ausbildungsplätze sichern
corona darf nicht wie blei am bein
hängen wenn es um den start ins
berufsleben geht deshalb ist das was wir
heute als schutzschirm für
ausbildungsplätze beschlossen haben ein
ganz wichtiger schritt mit bis zu 3000
euro aus bildungsprämie sollen kleine
und mittelständische unternehmen
unterstützt werden wenn sie weniger als
250 mitarbeiter haben das maritim
magdeburg mit seinen 170 angestellten
profitiert trotzdem nicht davon
es ist teil einer hotelkette wir sind
einfach zu groß
das heißt wir bis dato bekomme keine
fördergelder wieder für die
auszubildenden noch irgendwelche anderen
form von fördergeldern
das wäre natürlich ein thema also wenn
der mittelstand dar der als größere
mittelstand berücksichtigt werden würde
er ist natürlich sehr schön
warum werden nicht alle
ausbildungsbetriebe gleichermaßen
gefördert
das bundesministerium für arbeit und
soziales erklärt auf nachfrage
zitat eine förderung aller betriebe kann
schon angesichts der beschränkten
finanzmittel nicht erfolgen
arbeitsmarktexperten widersprechen
man hätte angesichts der konjunkturellen
situation auch an eine generelle aus
bildungsprämie denken können beteiligt
befristet das darf nicht zum
dauerzustand werden aber aktuell gerne
eine generelle aus bildungsprämie die
einfach jede ausbildung unterstützt um
den markt noch ein bisschen stärker zu
stabilisieren hamburg in vielen branchen
brechen die einnahmen weg besonders
betroffen ist der tourismus
auszubildende violett alkohol stehen vor
einer ungewissen zukunft
sie ist in ihrem zweiten lehrjahr in
einem reisebüro seit märz wickelt sie
vor allem stornierungen ab ich weiß
wirklich nicht warum das bei ihnen nicht
funktioniert hat es ist wirklich komisch
krisenmanagement statt kundenberatung
ferne ziele und traumreisen gibt es
derzeit nur im katalog wie lange das
noch gut geht weiß sie nicht also
momentan hoffe ich halt dass ich hier
meine ausbildung erst mal beenden kann
ich möchte auf jeden fall im tourismus
bleiben deswegen macht es schon ein
bisschen angst dass jetzt halt auch
viele veranstalter und viele reisebüros
pleite gehen das ist so macht schon ein
bisschen angst ihr chef klaus peter süd
sein unternehmen derzeit mit den
soforthilfen der bundesregierung über
wasser
seine angestellte ist zu hause in
kurzarbeit
seit vielen jahren bildet der
familienbetrieb nachwuchs aus bei juli
darko aber ist alles anders
das hauptgeschäft ist ja das verkaufen
von reisen und da hat sie natürlich
jetzt leider ein kleines problem dass da
viel was von dem was sie erklären soll
jetzt nicht gesagt werden konnte
bei der praktischen ausbildung im
reisebüro werden die lücken immer größer
doch zumindest der theoretische teil an
der hamburger handels schule läuft für
juli dahlke und ihre mitschülerinnen
noch nach plan
nur was nützt das wenn der
ausbildungsplatz verloren geht
johanna schütze war bei einem
reiseveranstalter der ende des monats
schließen muss jetzt weiß ich nicht bis
wollen wir weitergehen soll und wie ich
irgendwie mal in die prüfung gehen soll
weil man ja auch gewisse eine gewisse
zeit gearbeitet haben muss um zur
prüfung zugelassen zu werden also zur
schule gehen kann ich weiterhin aber
sind dann auch nur zwei tage die woche
und dann habe ich ja noch den rest der
woche und kann man aber nicht kann jetzt
ist mit nicht mehr zur arbeit gehen
nochmal für beide schülerinnen gäbe es
durchaus eine lösung nicht im ständigen
wechsel schule und betrieb sondern
zunächst den theoretischen teil an der
berufsschule und erst danach die praxis
im betrieb
wenn der arbeitsmarkt sich verbessert
könnten jugendliche war sie nach
demselben clan unterrichtet werden
könnten jugendliche auch nach dem ersten
oder nach dem zweiten ausbildungsjahr in
eine betriebliche ausbildung wechseln
und es dort beenden
das hat sich schon bewährt in der
wirtschaftskrise 2005 doch die dafür
zuständige kultusminister konferenz
lehnt dies jetzt ab zitat die duale
ausbildung ist ein modell für das
deutschland bekannt ist
deshalb sollten wir an diesen
etablierten strukturen festhalten
kein ausbildungsplatz kein abschluss
kein berufseinstieg so haben junge
menschen in corona zeiten kaum eine
chance auf dem arbeitsmarkt zu bestehen